it's not going to get easier it's going
to get harder so we might as well do it
now pull off the band-aid eat our peas
all anybody in Washington can talk about
these days is the debt limit or debt
ceiling the total amount of money the
federal government is authorized to
borrow at any given time after a decade
in which spending increased by more than
sixty percent in inflation-adjusted
dollars and the debt limit was raised no
fewer than ten times the government is
about to max out its fourteen point
three trillion dollar credit line
leading to fears that Washington is
going to default on its bonds stop
cutting social security checks and
destroy the economy more than it already
has but the current debate over the debt
ceiling is full of malarkey for at least
three reasons Treasury Secretary Timothy
Geithner is push back the drop-dead date
when the u.s. finally reaches its limit
a bunch of times already March 31st
April fifteenth and May 31st were all
cited as deadlines before August second
was inked in for Armageddon but this
time he means it man really
reaching the debt limit is not the same
as the faulting on our debt which would
indeed be catastrophic think about it
you can max out your credit cards but as
long as you keep paying the minimum
amount to each month your creditors
don't go crazy interest on the debt is a
small fraction of total outlays and the
government has a series of tools from
using cash on hand to selling assets to
scrimping on non-essential payments to
make sure that interest payments are
made and seniors aren't put on an all
cat food diet the reason we're in this
mess is because government can't stop
spending and the government can't even
pass a budget on a year's notice but
we're expecting them to come up with a
good plan for the country's borrowing in
a couple of weeks try to force an
expansion of the country's credit line
by promising cuts in spending down the
road is exactly why we're in this
situation to begin with it makes far
more sense to do something like sell
some tarp assets the government is
sitting on 320 billion dollars in
outstanding direct loans and equity
investments to cover interest payments
through the end of the fiscal year then
force Congress and the president to come
up with a budget that cuts spending and
borrowing for real next year not in some
distant future for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you